a good rule of thumb is that people
chronically underestimate intangible
value right this familiarity that I'm
sure a lot of people have with good
hearts law that once we have a measure
it ceases to be a reliable measure as we
over optimize around that think about
you know you're talking about Instagram
you know think about once you decide
that followers is an important metric
you start to over optimized towards
followers versus thinking about how do I
increase engagement how do I get these
people to convert to something that I
want them to do etc that if we can
understand what are these things that
are bringing intangible value to us
things that we can't necessarily measure
but have an effect right across our
entire system we can find ways to unlock
hidden value because everyone is over
tied to things that are very easy to
reduce to a number I'm joined by Chris
sparks founder of the forcing function
and form a top 20 online poker players
in the world we are talking all things
productivity Chris welcome the show hey
Chris hey guys thank you so much for
having me absolute pleasure to have you
one recently had one of your peers
Thiago Forte talking about tools also
had not a liason host of the made you
think podcast saying that you and Thiago
are the only two people in the world
that he listens to about productivity so
no no pressure mate no pressure
thanks I'll do my best so why don't you
give us a little bit of a background
before we delve into the the dark world
of productivity why don't we why don't
we hear a little bit about you yeah
certainly so I kind of got into this
through the side door as you mentioned I
think a lot of people know me for my
online poker career I still play at a
pretty high level but I had my my peak
right before the event we called Black
Friday so you know 2008 to 2011 and I
learned quite a bit during that time
about what it takes to perform at the
high
level and I realized that the people who
were doing things that I saw is shaping
the world we're all becoming
entrepreneurs some of my other some of
my poker poker players friends included
and I wanted to find a way that I could
take all of the things that I had
learned about peak performance and find
a way to accelerate the growth of these
people who I thought were putting things
into the world that needed to exist and
so that's how I stumbled upon founding
the forcing function where I take
everything that I have learned about how
to produce at a very high level so
become the sort of person who can
accomplish anything that you want
whether that's installing habits or
systems or just removing roadblocks to
accomplishing ones goals and I've
created a system which I put together in
my just release book experiment without
limits which I'm happy to talk about I
work do workshops I do one-on-one
coaching and it's it's something that
allows me to have you know really
interesting conversations just like this
one get to learn something new every day
yeah well don't speak too soon might not
be might not be interesting you I might
boy asleep but yes I totally get it man
the world of online poker seems to be
like a bit of a breeding ground for
people that are polymaths in other areas
or people that are real extreme high
performers think a lot about Josh
Waitzkin as well former chess prodigy
now turned executive CEO coach and all
that sort of stuff it seems to there
must be some real some real intellects
in there absolutely I mean I'm a huge
fan of what Josh is doing and the way
that I see it is that there's so many
things that are transferable I mean you
see you see this in Silicon Valley you
see this on Wall Street that poker is
generally a training ground for business
and that's the way that I see it as
entrepreneurs the what we're doing all
day is really making decisions right
decisions on what to focus decisions on
what audience to go after how
reach them where to spend our limited
time and I see poker as a very important
framework on being able to make better
decisions within perfect information and
so when you're playing poker at a high
level not only do you have to beat other
players but you have to conquer yourself
that we are the common denominator and
all of our productivity struggles and so
understanding what our own triggers are
understanding how things can go off the
rails or you know in the positive side
what are the conditions that allow us to
have peak focus to how it allows to have
peak energy and how can we recreate
those conditions where if you understand
what you're trying to accomplish it's
more or less understanding whether these
conditions that I need to have in order
to put myself in the position to
accomplish that I totally understand so
when you were going through online poker
and you were looking at the potential
for the forcing function who was some of
the people you've mentioned Josh it was
some of the other people that you
thought wow that that's someone that I
really need to learn from or someone
whose particular stance I really respect
or you had admiration for like that was
there anyone who comes to mind that you
thought is a role model in that oh man
that's that's a really good question you
know I'll take a step backwards and how
I approach all of this is I see my
personal system as a collection of the
best other people systems so as a poker
player what you're doing is anytime
someone makes a move against you that
puts you on your heels but you're not
sure with the right responses you
realize hey if I don't know what I'm
supposed to do here this is probably a
good thing to be doing to other people
right they probably stumbled upon a good
strategy even if I don't understand it
yet and so looking to emulate one part
of that strategy until you can
internalize the reasoning behind it
right and so the same way when you're
looking at you know who do I want to
emulate
I always start from you know do I want
this person's life
right this person giving advice like do
I want to have a life that's similar to
theirs where none no like one dimension
can be taken away outside of the whole
system right so people look at someone
who's hyper hyper productive but the
question is you know do you want to be
that person the answer is no right
classic examples everyone really admires
Warren Buffett no necessarily wants to
be Warren Buffett right I mean maybe
Warren Buffett 50 years ago but hey I
digress
so where I'm looking for is who are
people who are living in a way that is
an alignment with the way that I'd like
to live and high-level I want to be
learning every single day I want to go
to bed slightly better than when I woke
up as far as I know something else I've
discovered want something new about how
the world works I understand myself a
little bit better and so when I'm
looking for examples I'm looking for
people who embody that now that being
said it can be really interesting to
look at true believers people who have a
fully fleshed out system let's see a
couple people come to mind I mean I'm as
far as pretty good fan of David Allen
don't necessarily want to be David Allen
huge fan of Nasim Talab don't
necessarily want to be Nassim Taleb but
I can take off pieces of their system
people who are very very opinionated
about all things what are the things
that resonate with me and how can i
integrate pieces of what they're doing
into my own system I think a big error
that many people make that they get onto
this personal development treadmill is
that they keep switching systems
wholesale rather than taking off pieces
of what other people are doing forming
what I call small experiments like if I
add this if I make this small change
does it have effect on myself overall if
does I can double down if not I stop it
and where a lot of people see is like oh
this new tool this new system like this
is going to change my life this is going
to solve anything and the the problem is
that none of these things are going to
solve your own problems because we are
always the calm
and the ironic thing is that this
incremental approach in that I changed
one small thing every day in a positive
direction adds it to compound returns
and that's the true way that progress is
incredibly accelerated not these
one-time heavy lifts of today's the day
that I change everything type of stuff
yeah I mean I'm laughing for a number of
reasons firstly because Jordan who is
one of the guys it's a part of the
modern wisdom project often uses a quote
from Navarre which is talking about you
can't just have a piece of someone's
life you have to have the whole and that
just for people that are listening it's
a really lovely tool to use and
especially I've done a little bit
reality TV I swim in waters of Instagram
influences and stuff like that and a lot
of people desire that right like they
look at that person and they think
either to cool life or that person too
got that this and that going on and it's
like I'm telling you from firsthand
experience that a lot of those people
you would not be able to be paid to have
their lights it looks good some of the
bits are great but some of the bits
aren't you totally right as well the
person who's incredibly industrious you
know you have no idea what Elon Musk's
relationship with his father's like you
have no idea what Elon Musk's bed like
routine in terms of his headspace is
like on a nighttime it's great to say
that this guy's taking us to Mars and
that he's making it Tesla's this amazing
cool company and he is but you only see
especially now with how curated and
social media feeds are you only see what
people want you to see and then when
there's a scandal and something happens
and it comes out that Jeff Bezos has
been sending dick pics around or
whatever it might be like everyone's
super shocked because we never get to
see that side of people and I think that
a much more rounded view and seeing
things in that ways is a lot more
interesting another one of the reasons
why I'm laughing and I'm sure a lot of
the listeners at home will be we have an
entire series called the life hacks now
these are to be done in a very piecemeal
fashion that we literally did one the
other day which is how to make the best
toasty like how you make the best
toasted sandwich and we all gave our
opinions on the best toasted sandwich
and then sometimes we'll do things we'll
use tools for such a short period of
time
in between recording the episode and
releasing it which is usually maybe two
to three weeks we'll have gone from the
new relationship status loving it to not
so sure about it too no longer using it
and then I'm about to publish the
episode and I'm good I might be talking
about something I don't even use now so
yeah the falling into the trap of this
is going to fix all of my problems is
such a huge big deal and you see this
all the time right like some of the guys
that are in the office that I work in
will come in with something new that
they believe is going to be the solution
to what it is that they do one of the
lads got hold of a [ __ ] ton of modafinil
the other day and they're all doing the
resets from uni because their big party
boys make him any type man like let's
get on this mode after I'm gonna do this
underneath it all right guys all of you
are taking modafinil and you've got your
notifications on your phone next to your
laptop like am I not seeing like there's
no one else seeing what I'm seeing here
like don't focus on the quick fix focus
on the big problem but yeah I think it's
so much of the stuff that you've said
they're really two strikes a chord with
with my experience as well personally
and it's difficult not to get seduced
right you see that clickbait title like
it's like for me and perhaps for
yourself as well it's the equivalent of
like I don't know like a hot girl advert
or something in you're like ah it
triggers something in me so primal like
these ten new productivity hacks for
iMessage I'm like got to see these new
productivity hacks for iMessage I got to
go and have a look and then I get in
there and I'm like you've done it again
you got clickbait if you thought it was
gonna be really cool but yeah honestly
absolutely everything personal personal
observation and personal experience I
totally agree
couple things there I'd love to of the
touch on so many interesting threads
here in first you mentioned of all and
one of his favorite ideas that I really
try to internalize this idea of a single
player game that the only thing that
matters is our internal scorecard and
how our own personal definition of
success right and that it's impossible
to look
and Turman weather people around us are
successful because we don't know what
their goals are right where we're
continually projecting based on our own
definitions and as you alluded to many
times we don't take the cost into
account this is what I call
differentiating goals from dreams you
know as everyone wants to be a rockstar
no one wants to play 300 shows and live
out of out of the back of a van for a
year right is like everyone wants the
results but no one wants to put in the
gym time and the reason that you know we
keep kicking ourselves is because we
haven't reconciled all right well if I
want to achieve this goal this is what
it's going to take and more importantly
due to opportunity cost here are all the
things that I'm going to have to give up
right that life is just one delicious
buffet but you can't eat it all you have
to pick and choose to do some things at
the expense of some things you also want
to do but not quite as much and it's
it's this nefarious justification in the
hindsight mirror that what we're doing
is okay it's like oh yeah that time I
spent reading you know how do how to
hack iMessage productivity hacks I'm
really glad that I read that but was
that how you chose to spend your time in
advance or you just backwards
rationalizing yeah shocking right where
so much of our mental bandwidth is
dedicated towards backwards
rationalizing oh yeah that what I'm
doing is great and that that's is really
really the importance of planning that
everything reduces down to what do you
want and once you understand that you
can get yourself to want anything it's
what do I want to want how do I sculpt
my environment so that my values
automatically coalesce around what I'm
doing and it's this fear I have being in
this productivity game that so many
people follow and listen to things like
this as entertainment as I am going to
feel better listening to this because I
have all these ideas that oh if I if I
start hugging people for five seconds
instead of three seconds I'm going to
have a little bit more empathy and if I
if I lower my voice one octave I'm gonna
have twenty seven twenty percent more
trust when our
actually doing the hard work of looking
down and understanding what do you want
and thinking about skill acquisition as
a just-in-time process what are the
skills that are in the way of
accomplishing your goals and worrying
about those rather than having this you
know giant collection of things that you
might actually use someday the the point
about using it as entertainment is so
right like you don't know the people
that wrote that I do the show with but
it sounds like you do that all of us are
the same and journey and easier for both
to sort of reel and George as well
another one of the guys it's part of the
project very very focused on the results
I I don't think I can get any of them to
read a fiction book but if I if can you
poor or Ryan holiday or whoever brings a
new book out they'll be straight on it
and bizarrely I think it applies a lot
of pressure to them and some listeners
at home might be striking a chord with
this too unless they can see a direct
result from the investment of reading
something there are a lot of the time
they're not going to read it it's
reading for this weird profit sort of
sake and I I caught myself doing that
and then have managed to backtrack quite
a bit the rule if for anyone who is
listening the heuristic that I've used
is that I will read nonfiction by day
but by night I'll only read fiction or
story based stuff just I don't want my
brain sort of sparking away in that sort
of a manner just before I'm about to go
to bed yeah but yeah like one of the
problems with that is if the only time
that you read is to read to make a
profit there's an awful lot of pressure
on what you're reading like you have to
unless you can do recall and unless you
can do recall with high fidelity and
then unless you can implement there's
always this like you're always gonna
feel guilty or at least I I found myself
feeling that like oh I reread you read
the five chapters of car new pods deep
work but only implemented one of them
that what a waste because there's this
desire for profit on the back end yeah
and and I think doing anything out of a
sense of guilt is really poor fuel I try
to
identify anything that I'm doing out of
a sense of obligation or fear and
ruthlessly eliminate that because I want
to enjoy everything that I do or it
needs to be very clear towards my goals
and putting this pressure on yourself
that Oh like I need to be extracting the
maximum value out of everything is is
not only irrational it's not healthy
that we need to relax
we need to recharge we need to unplug
and everything doesn't need to exactly
tie to a goal I mean I'm really big on
reading fiction I've actually cut way
way down on reading nonfiction because I
mean any book especially around 200
pages doesn't actually need to be 200
pages it's a 20 page blog post with 180
pages of examples or stories around that
does that sound a little bit like
fiction to you right it's a very it's a
very blurred line and when you're
thinking about how do you actually
maximize your time reading sometimes
reading the thing that takes four hours
is actually gonna be a lower hourly ROI
than something that takes 20 hours
because the 20-hour thing is
high-quality enough then it transforms
the paradigms with which you view the
world enough that everything you do
changes after that and that's that's why
I really love fiction Plus that you know
I happen to enjoy it and I want to read
things that I enjoy that the subset of
books exist in the world that are both
important and useful and enjoyable is
far larger than the number of books that
I love to read I mean my reading this is
gonna be thousands of books long before
I die and I'm perfectly okay with that
yeah totally I read a so it's sacrilege
I know but I only read 1984 last year
and that book some of the conclusions
that I drew from that piss all over so
many nonfiction like productivity books
so much stuff that came out of that and
I was like this is this is as useful if
not more useful than something which
designs itself to be productivity so
yeah and the whole notion of speed
reading is that you can you can extract
information is it faster that the point
isn't to extract the information they
is to is to prompt yourself under
thinking and to sit with it and think
about ways to apply and it's the more
time that you spend with a book the more
you get out of it and it actually has
compounding returns rather than
diminishing returns I I mean that whole
notion of you know how do i how do I
take in information faster how do I
listen to this podcast at 3x instead of
two X's on it two and a half X I know
you do I know you've got this on at two
and a half times speed and Chris is
telling you to slow it down right now
yeah and I mean man I have so many rants
today it seems a good rule of thumb is
that people chronically underestimate
intangible value right this familiarity
that I'm sure a lot of people have with
good hearts law that once we have a
measure it ceases to be a reliable
measure as we over optimize around that
think about you know you're talking
about Instagram you know think about
once you decide that followers is an
important metric you start to over
optimized towards followers versus
thinking about how do I increase engage
in it how do I get these people to
convert to something that I want them to
do
etc that if we can understand what are
these things that are bringing
intangible value to us things that we
can't necessarily measure but have an
effect right across our entire system we
can find ways to unlock hidden value
because everyone is over tied to things
that are very easy to reduce to a number
and I think this is probably a good
transition to talk about experiment
without limits of it is the huge reason
why I decided to start it is because I
felt myself falling into this trap over
and over and over again is I can't do
anything to help people I don't know
enough I'm not enough of an expert I
don't what do I have to offer thinking
that knowledge is the limiting resource
for people and if knowledge was the
limiting resource man like these people
who are eating a hundred hundred books a
day like why aren't they going to space
right clearly clearly there's there's
something else that's missing in that
equation and that it's action right the
knowledge is
useful to the point that is getting in
the way of acting that we don't know
what to do and I realized that you know
from poker all we do is forward
information that that's how we went
against our opponents is information
asymmetry that I was carrying this over
to my personal life that I was hoarding
my information think that I thinking
that I had the secret I I and I decided
it's like I want to burn these bridges
by outsourcing I'm sorry by open
sourcing everything that I know and so I
took what it if I could only you know
the old like if we lost all information
about science Fineman is okay well we
know the universe is made from atoms we
can build everything up from that I was
like if if everything we had learned
about performance was forgotten what
could I share with people and so that
they could build up from that and find a
way to build upon these principles
install them in their in life's and that
was the birth of experiment without
limits is here is everything that I know
like take it for free and my hope is
that this will illuminate the
opportunities that people have and
actually spurn them to take the action
where the knowledge itself has no value
until they actually act upon it yeah so
having gone through experiment without
limits one of the things I have to say
first off is it is very action focused
every page is a task every task has a
time predictor of how long you think
it's going to take you there's like a
augmented and silly rule information
which is like this is something that you
might want to do when you're doing this
and all this sort of stuff a really cool
point I mean the middle of writing my
first ever online course and a really
cool point that I came across was from
LinkedIn and it said that the words
strategy or strategist is in the top 10
by your descriptors on all of LinkedIn
top ten words strategy or strategist but
executors or execution doesn't even
feature in the top 1,000 and I think
that that asymmetry of people who like
to plan versus people who like to do
people of talking versus people of
action
I think that you've hit upon a real a
real gem there which is just by doing
stuff and learning by doing and just
trying things out you get a lot further
than kind of this circle-jerk of
information slash read in such whatever
it might be that's my hope as I'm trying
to get myself out of the treadmill these
are all the things that I follow and I
keep coming back to them and I know that
if I think that's one of these hacks is
something that's holding you back
I should just redo one of these
experiments instead that I'm clearly
missing something obvious as far as an
opportunity or bottleneck yeah I get it
so let's let's take us through what do
you think people need to know first from
experiment without limits or if you were
doing a Productivity MOT for someone if
you're having a little bit of a
breakdown I'm gonna taking them into the
garage looking under the hood why would
you stop yeah so I would say it breaks
into two parts so the first part is the
fundamentals right so you need to have
the fundamentals down before you start
optimizing right thinking about your
your co-producer who's taking modafinil
before he hasn't turned off his
notifications right yeah there's there's
these last mile solutions that everyone
wants to jump to before they have the
strong foundation and for me the
Foundation's are goals systems and
habits and routines all right so first
goals i structure out how you can figure
out what you want and how you can frame
it in such a way that it's achievable
it's actionable that you know when you
will achieved it all right once you once
you know what you want you have a very
easy litmus test for things that are on
the path that are not on the path
systems is more or less my way of
thinking about how do I accelerate
progress around that path how do I make
it easier to make progress and it really
focuses on these three key principles of
leverage bottlenecks and feedback loops
so leverage how do I get more for Less
bottlenecks how do I identify what is
most holding me back and then feedback
loops how do I know if I'm making
progress right
how do I know if my efforts are tracking
towards my goal habits and routines you
know everyone knows how to create habits
how knows how to create routines but
it's something that's very easy but not
simple and so I'm really trying to break
down if you follow this system you will
be able to install and you have it every
month all right that's 12 new habits a
year how many people start 12 you habits
here thousands millions how many people
will actually add 12 habits a year I
would say you know one in a hundred
people and all that comes down to is
just adding one at a time and making the
everyone knows kind of the power of
habit but people actually don't think
through and practice and plan out when
they create a habit what the trigger is
how do I make it ridiculously easy to do
and why am i doing it and the kind of
you know outline those the step-by-step
portion and then the second half the
assumption is once you have all these
place that the system is is you know
humming running well how do you optimize
so you have your key resources of time
attention energy how do you maximize
those so time is really getting your
planning and reflection down so I call
this the cycle of I plan what I'm going
to do I have that experiment I collect
data I reflect how did that go and based
on that everything is a double down or
stop and so I'm constantly having a
bunch of these experiments going one in
each dimension so that I ensured
progress and all the things that are
important to me attention you're talking
about notifications attention is
primarily about understanding that
everything that is not your top priority
at this keepin' moment is a distraction
so how do you create a default so that
the thing that is the most important
thing right now is the only thing you
were going to do and that everything
else you you make it harder you add
friction to it energy we've tried my
last mile how do you get your sleep your
exercise your diet nailed in automatic
solved so that you don't even have to
think about it and then we can talk
about now what do you next as far as you
know caffeine supplements etc but you
know
9% of the value unlocked there is sleep
nutrition exercise and then I go into
what I call more mental games this is a
lot of crossover from poker in your
motivation so how do you get yourself to
do hard things how do you show up when
things aren't going well how do you get
yourself back on track how do you debug
yourself so getting into procrastination
getting into you know ensuring you know
accountability and consistency and then
my final is probably the my favorite
chapter in that a core belief for me is
that we can become and achieve anything
that we want and the meta skill there is
learning how to learn that the only
thing that's in the way of our goals is
the skills necessary to achieve them so
the final chapter accelerating learning
I break down my process for self
transformation and how do you acquire
any skill in an extremely efficient
manner recently we had Scott young
author of ultra learning on last year
had Peter C Brown author of make it
stick Thiago Forte's been on earlier
this year James clear author of atomic
habits has been on earlier this year it
does seem to me like everyone is kind of
circling around a lot of the things that
were talking about today why do you
think it is that so many people have
this as I say obsession but I'm going to
use the word this obsession with
optimizing and and productivity
obviously we all want to get more done
in less time but is it just that no one
or a lot of people aren't finding the
solution or sticking to the program and
therefore there's constantly a gap in
the market there's someone to come up
with something new is that why or is it
something else I wonder whether you've
thought of that I'm happy to guess I I
would say that there there are a couple
different schools of thought right so
why now why are people so interested in
optimization I think it's this
you know transparency due to we can see
what everyone else is doing and it's
never been easier to compare ourselves
with our peers and particularly to
pair ourselves with the best possible
version of our peers what they want us
to see and so I think a lot of it really
is driven by competitiveness in that we
are we are relativistic creatures right
we're concerned about our position in
the pecking order and we want to improve
relative to our peers now the positive
spin on that you know why why habits why
now a lot of the research on behavioural
change is so well-established in the
psychological literature and really has
not changed since the seventies right
what are the best practices today
haven't really changed all that much in
the last few decades you know now this
will put in a nut counter to would have
you know a lot of magazines and articles
will tell you right you know like men's
health needs to put out a new workout
every year you know sorry every episode
and you know there needs to be a new
diet for people to try that people are
gonna go through phases but the core
habits underlying these behaviors the
science there has not changed at all and
why I think people are so interested is
because we feel like we are powerless
that more and more of what we do every
day feels outside of our own control
right we're drowning in messages we're
drowning in emails there are so many
things that we could be doing and we've
never been more aware of all the things
that we quote-unquote should be doing
but don't have the time to do we don't
have the energy to do and so we look for
solutions outside ourselves right
everyone becomes a true believer of a
system and I think a lot of people
finally settle on you know what my
consensus belief is that the solution
lies within ourselves
and that if we can become the sort of
person who can change our behavior as
needed who can learn any skill that we
become we increase our own capability we
feel more confident moving about the
world we feel you know less less
self-conscious and exposed went on the
internet and I'm very I'm very very
supportive of this this movement
but as always like my concern is that
people treat it as entertainment as they
read about the solution and think
they've accomplished it right that
knowledge is not the action and that's
that's my hope is you know I talked
about James clear like I read I read
James clears book and for me someone
who's been immersed in this world I
think well there's not really much new
that's here but he has put it more
directly and concisely than just about
anyone else and it has reached a very
wide audience to people who can actually
implement these into focus and you know
that's my hope is that people don't
treat this as a beat read but they
actually go and take the next step say
all right given this information how do
I apply it what is the next step what's
the action that I take yeah I think it
would be difficult for someone to go
through this and treat it as a beach
read it's so action focused there is a
lot in there you know even just the use
of some of the the highlight tabs for
particular tasks and stuff like that
it's like um if you've been to a
restaurant and they've got like a
featured meal like a featured meal of
the month it's like your eyes
immediately get drawn to that if you're
on a beach and you use this as a b-tree
that would be I'll be impressed and
surprised also what you said about
James's book is exactly the first thing
I said to him I was like being honest
James wasn't a massive amount that was
new in atomic habits to me but I've
never seen it all put together in the
same place and displayed with such
wonderful examples and hopefully with
this this will be something similar so
why don't we why don't we go through and
why don't you pick we can either go
through each chapter or why don't we go
through a couple of chapters and why
don't you give us your favorite this is
gonna be like making you choose your
favorite child here why don't you choose
your favorite task from within either
all or a couple of sections or something
like that all right
okay so maybe we'll do we've been
talking about habits so maybe we'll kind
of start with with habits routines and
then I can switch to one of the
or or prescriptive kind of optimization
chapters out for that amazing um so my
key takeaway from habits is that our
future behavior is deterministic right
that it's it's not only true it's also
useful to think about your future self
as not having free will right that you
do not choose what you're going to do in
the future but that your actions are
determined by the context that you find
yourself in and right so to unpack that
we take actions now that change what we
do in the future right so one aspect of
that is everything that we do makes it
more likely that action is repeated in
the future so thinking about habits
right it's I use this metaphor of a
river digging a path through rock you
think about like you know the river that
created the Grand Canyon over millions
of years and so on the good end
everything that we do reinforces that we
do that again right
every time we complete a habit that is
positive reinforcer identity as someone
who does that on the other side when we
have something that we call a quote
unquote bad habit that we don't want to
be repeating realizing that we have
carved a path through the rock and that
it takes time to refill that river with
sand but that every time we have this
impulse and we say no the level rises a
little bit right so I think of this as
an upstream effect and that in order to
change our behavior I don't try to do
anything in the present I don't do
things I make things easier to do in the
future or if I don't want to do them I
make them harder to do in the future by
adding friction right so if you
understand and internalize that you can
change your behavior in any direction
that you want and so the how-to of that
right the everyone knows this trigger
behavior reward but I'll just take you
know 60 seconds to break this down into
how do you actually implement that so
think about like with the trigger
trigger sets it in motion so we'll use
good habits
example would use the universe for bad
habits like if you want a habit to
happen understand what triggers it and
make sure that trigger happens make sure
that you notice it make sure that you do
next is very clear make sure that you
can't avoid it and I have like a
checklist that you can follow specific
consistent automatic avoid unavoidable
and if you if you look at all of the
things that you want to do and identify
that trigger and make sure that trigger
does all four of those things the habit
takes care of itself you don't have to
do anything else where people forget to
do things is that they forget about
their trigger or and they don't have a
system to ensure that that trigger
occurs and that they notice it behavior
at a high level how do you make it as
easy as possible right so when you're
first starting off a habit I always
recommend something that takes two
minutes or less so you have no excuses
and it is like Auto opt in that you just
it just happens like not worrying about
the results right everyone has this half
heavy lifter and like you haven't worked
out it's January first and now all of a
sudden you're gonna go to the gym every
day for two hours well that's not gonna
work out too well but if it's alright
you know at you know 9:00 a.m. after
brushing my teeth I'm going to do five
push-ups every single day right how can
you say no to doing five push-ups but
before you know you have it chained you
can start to build off of where five can
become ten can become I go outside and
do push-ups can we go I run around the
block for 10 minutes etc and before you
know it you know your Olympic
weightlifter the final is like reward
it's very important to understand why
you are doing a habit first you know
connecting it to a long-term goal you
know what why are you doing this in the
first place how does it tie to your
goals but also having an immediate
reinforcement so the intrinsic reward is
why is this important extrinsic reward
is why is this immediately reward me so
we've been using gym as an example all
right so I want to work out why because
I want to look good why because I want
to feel confident when I'm out right or
I want to feel better I want to have
more energy why so I can make more
progress towards my goal
as I can build my business etc the
extrinsic reward is you walking outside
of the gym man I feel really
accomplished
oh this like sore feeling feels really
good I can post on my Instagram a photo
of like how I look with my shirt shirt
off you know no point it not not
pointing anything is there yeah I can
you know I could talk to a friend right
a friend meets me at the gym and I have
that that social aspect that feels good
right if you have these three elements
in place trigger easy behavior reward
you create a strong foundation for a
habit that automatically expands with
time and the smaller and stronger that
foundation the easier it is to expand
but where people mess up when it comes
to habits is that they take on too much
too soon and then anything happens right
they go on a trip their schedules too
busy for the day they miss a day and all
of a sudden they're starting back at
zero as William James puts it like
they've let the ball of yarn unroll and
have to spend all the effort unrolling
that ball again so one experiment that I
really love here this is in the chapter
for routines right where routine is just
a collection of habits that you that's
up that reinforce each other is that you
actually walk through your routine and
practice it and so the example that I
give that's a really common one for
people is getting out of bed right away
and so I recommend people simulate
waking up in the morning with their
alarm and just getting out of bed
turning off their alarm and going about
their day over and over and over again
before it's automatic practicing it I've
been hitting any ways that they could
they could get off track and adding
friction to those way so making it
really hard to hit snooze and the more
automatic it is the easier it is and
you're like well I don't want to spend a
half hour practicing your routine think
about like this half an hour could save
you months and how long it takes for
this to actually become solidified so
that's a really powerful one I call that
offline training highly how they
recommend that's cool I've got so much
so many
threads open here left to go through
here so I'll work backwards first off my
solution for getting out of bed has
actually been to get a sunrise alarm
clock which I absolutely love everyone
who's listening will know that I'm a big
fan of that but it's on the other side
of the bedroom so to get up and turn it
off I got to walk over it is also next
to my window which is X the curtains
open the curtains I forgot to turn the
alarm off might as well open the
curtains I'm not getting back to bed
like it is this huge window in front of
my bedroom like I'm not I'm not gonna go
back to bed after that also please I
know that when we're tool agnostic today
I'm the I'm a part of the the Chris
Chris sparks ideology today and we are
to like Gnostic however for the love of
God please do not sleep with your phone
in your bedroom just put it in the
kitchen put it somewhere else like the
probably the single best thing that I've
done in the last three years of
improving myself has been not having my
phone in my bedroom and every time that
I go away and I stay in a hotel
or I'm on holiday I'm reminded of why I
do it because I forget I just put it
next to the thing and I'll set my alarm
I'm going aloud and I'm like I'll have
watched five YouTube videos and don't
I've just fallen back into that old
habit right but yeah please keep it
outside your bedroom move him back up um
you mentioned about allowing yourself to
sit with the good feeling and to give
yourself a reward Rick Hanson in
hardwiring happiness episode say
something sorry Rick didn't episode with
him on resilience his new book totally
stopped talking about resilience and
just went deep on hardwiring happiness
but hard-wearing happiness allow
yourself to sit with good emotions he
suggests for between five and ten
seconds when you do something good
let it flow gee-day and I really love
that another element of that which it
forces you to do is to take time away
from your phone or any other sort of
stimulus because you're quite engaged
with the stimulus that is just you and I
think that's quite that's quite a lovely
thing to to happen and then with regards
to what you mentioned in the beginning
which is the upstream effort a lot of
people say to myself and some of the
other guys that I work with that I am
honestly I'm such a bad procrastinator
at university all I did
my assignments in like on the day I did
a master's dissertation in 36 hours and
I did 80% of the word count in the last
36 hours I'm terrible and the fact that
I'm even slightly competent and able to
do the fact I'm able to get myself out
of bed and get dressed in the morning
like fairly a miracle but I do a couple
of businesses and I do this podcast and
I do a couple of other little bits and
pieces and to some people that might
seem like I'm doing a lot and yeah in
the first place it was hard like when I
started trying to publish one podcast a
week I was I oh my god like this is
taking a long time the systems haven't
got my systems in place it takes me
longer it's effortful [ __ ] I keep making
mistakes and then I stepped it up at the
beginning of this year I made a promise
to the listeners that unless as long as
I'm in the country they'll get two
episodes a week and then after a month I
was like you [ __ ] idiot like you've
just like totally Lynch pinned yourself
to this ridiculous workload and now if I
don't record to a week
I feel like lonely I'm like broken or
anyone this week I better do for next
week and I find myself like on Saturday
morning I had the guy that created
titania McGrath and Reed oil had him in
and I'd only had four hours of sleep but
I was like I want to get up I want to
talk to Andrew and I'd do that and now
the editing process is refined and all
the rest of it so yes getting more
things and fitting more things into your
life is difficult in the first place and
that's why starting small is effective
but all the time as you become more and
more proficient at those things and you
your processes either become more
refined or your capability goes up or
you know going tim ferrissí perhaps you
might start outsourcing some of this
sort of stuff like all of that all of
that allows you over time to do an Elon
Musk like Elon Musk might not actually
work 80 hours a week
he might just work 40 hours a week but
be able to do the work at 80 hours
because he's incredibly efficient with
his time or he might be whatever so yeah
that's those are my those are my
thoughts there Chris I've run I've run
back up the line there mate yeah maybe
we should talk about procrastination
let's do it I really need some help with
that yeah
I think you touched on a very important
concept which is you know when the first
hour you win the day that how you start
the day really matters as far as setting
the tone and that having something
that's important to you that gets you
excited and out of bed is maybe the
important first important thing that you
have right the no amount of productivity
techniques are going to get you to want
to do something that you don't want to
do right so start with start with a goal
that feels good that's important to you
and that everything that you pick up you
need to put something else down right
that productivity usually comes from
doing less things rather than more but
you do things of higher average
importance right and so you accomplish
more by saying all right I'd like to do
both of these but this is more important
so I'm going to put my focus here first
and then I switch I talk about this as
serial rather than parallel so the key
to procrastination is getting started
right
once you're moving all right a body at
rest tends to stay at rest a body in
motion tends to stay in motion just like
do whatever you can to get moving
think about this as a verb change like I
am going to publish a podcast - I am
publishing a podcast I'm going to write
a blog article - I am writing right
there's a very subtle difference and all
you do is you write the first word you
open the document right take the very
first step and so conquering
procrastination is finding the reason
that you are not starting and
reconciling that argument with yourself
so that you start and before you know it
you're underway one of the fins to
interject there one of the things that
Laura van de Kamp talked about I don't
know whether you're familiar with
Laura's work off the clock so she's a
time management expert highly recommend
I'll send you the that's it I'm gonna
get another play here I'll send you the
podcast once I'm done and on that she
has this really cool little way that she
reframes things things that she doesn't
do and a lot of the time people say I
don't have time to do X I don't have
time to do Y whereas she brings that
whenever she catches herself doing that
she says it's not a priority
it's not a priority because that changes
it from being outside of your control to
being in your control and it forces you
to question actually how much do I want
this thing and if I do want this thing
and I'm not doing it why I really like
that reframing it strikes a chord is
what you just mentioned yeah I think
that's a very it's a very good thread
that we've been coming back to that you
know time how we spend it is a
reflection of our priorities and that if
we're not doing something there's a
reason right and getting in touch with
that reason understanding why is a much
more effective way of discovering why we
are doing it or if it's even worth doing
in the first place so we can eliminate
that guilt we're feeling about it and
you know sleep better at night be
happier etc I love what you're talking
about as far as Rick Hansen we're
focusing on our subjective experience in
how can we make the things we're going
to do anyway more enjoyable and a habit
that he recommends is take literally one
minute after you do something and just
say wow like wasn't that great wasn't
that fun aren't I glad I accomplished
that and the transformation that makes
me go throughout life saying wow like
this is so much fun like I can't believe
I get to do this I can't believe people
pay me for that versus like oh my god
like Monday again I got to show up and
do this and do that right it's it's if
we enjoy things we eliminate a lot of
this perceived activation energy to get
started
I mean you touched on something that's
very core to me which I call is a
forcing function where you put something
in place that changes your default
behavior right where before your default
behavior would have been alright well
I'll put a podcast out when I feel like
it right when I have time but you made
this commitment to your audience that
says I'm going to put two episodes out a
week and then you have to reorganize
your personal system to follow through
with that progress with that promise
right you've created a new default is
like well I'm going to find a way to put
two episodes out a week I have now
created that as a top priority and now
my time will have to reflect that
and all this is I talked about like the
reflection planning cycle is just
regularly reflecting you know where is
my time going and is it in line with my
priorities and if it's not you rebalance
your time portfolio you say all right
well I've been spending a lot of time on
this thing that's not really important
to me maybe I should spend something up
my time on something else has important
to say right it's like I say that
relationships are really important to me
but I haven't been keeping in touch with
my friends I haven't been spending time
with my significant other I say my
health is really important to me but I
haven't been setting a time aside to go
to the gym I haven't been setting a sign
aside to cook healthy food right and all
you do is do you just bring yourself
back into balance as far as putting more
time into what you say is a higher
priority at a high level this
procrastination chapter is identify why
you are procrastinating and then get rid
of that reason right so the four
categories are expectancy value and
pulse apna s-- and delay and so
expectancy that if I do this I will get
a reward right and so making sure that
you can increase your perceived chances
of success or that if you do succeed
there will be reward at the other end
value that you enjoy like you're going
to do and that the reward you will
receive is something that you place a
value on right so how can you do what
you're doing more and make make what
you're doing more enjoyable well we'll
come back to the I guess we'll keep
we'll use you as an example if you don't
mind Chris as far as producing a podcast
episode right so it's like how do i how
do I increase my chances that putting
effort into producing a podcast will
have the results that I want
how do I make the process of editing a
podcast which I know is a pain in the
butt or enjoyable right how can I you
know put on good music can I have some
friend come up who has a podcast over
come and do it with me etc impulsiveness
this is this is the attention chapter at
a nutshell is like our ability to focus
in the face of distractions so we make
these distractions harder to access so
everyone knows that as soon as we have
something we're procrastinating on
that's the time that we want to clean
our room right that's the time we want
to
organize our file structure like how do
we remove these options from our menu
and then finally delay a huge part of
procrastination is like we have to do
all the work with this [ __ ] in the
future it gets all the benefits so how
can we receive some of the benefits that
we get from putting in this effort
sooner and if you discover which one of
these four is most holding you back you
can immediately put something in place
that's like oh this is more enjoyable
this is more valuable and all it does is
it allows you to get started and once
you're moving you keep moving so I call
this the procrastination algorithm
notice why you're procrastinating try
something if it works start working if
not try something else and and it's
funny is that like you just go through
this process for like five or ten
minutes and you immediately start moving
because you discover oh well this is why
I'm not doing it
if I change this then I guess I will
start moving verses like you know you
start you know in hours or days or in
you know my case sometimes and you know
oh I'll start this book and months down
the line right it's it's just like take
that few minutes to like look at
yourself and say why am I not doing this
recognize this is actually a good reason
but I can I can reason with this reason
right I can I can strike a compromise
and that allows you to get moving I get
it
I totally get it I love the idea as well
what we're focusing on here with regards
to procrastination is the next step one
of the things that I use for me is why
is the smallest next step that I can
take that kind of puts me on the way
that so many of the guys that I'll speak
to so my company we run club nights we
deal with a lot of eighteen or
twenty-one year old students we would
call it uni you call it college and so
many of those guys are like our man like
I got this huge assignment to do I got
this that knew that I'm like first
question if you're struggling with it
have you made the file like we created
the Evernote or have you made the Word
document oh I haven't done that yet it's
like man just do that dude because that
is that is the first thing that before
the reading before that and it's so if
you're listening and you need to do an
assignment just make the file that is
the next step that you can do and you
told you I love the body of motion stays
in motion body a body at rest stays at
States it is the third law of
thermodynamics for procrastination is
perfect so what we got next what's your
next what's the next chapter that you on
have a little look at oh man I mean if
you don't cut me off I mean I would
probably because of the way that we
started I would probably end with with
learning right so cool we talked about
at the high level if we understand what
we want to accomplish we then identify
what are the skills we need to acquire
to accomplish this goal where it's very
easy to fall into the trap of here all
the things that would be fun to learn
today is like I would love to I would
love to speak five languages I want to
be able to throw ninja stars I want to
be able to do a handstand I'd like to be
able to you know to talk to 50 women a
day right it's like all like I had this
long list of things that I'd like to do
but the question is which one of these
is actually in the way of achieving what
you want so I call this identifying your
highest leverage skill first like what
is your most important goal what's the
biggest goal that you have right now and
then create a picture like what is the
version of yourself who is accomplishing
this goal right it's like what does a
day look like for them what are they
doing what are they capable of that you
are not yet capable of right whether you
it's not something you do or it's
something that you'd like to do a higher
level and then decide which one of these
is most on the path right if you only
pick to do one of these which most puts
you on the path towards a being this
person who can achieve this goal and
that takes you down from here's the long
list of things I'd like to do to here is
what I'm going to learn next and each
one of these skills that you acquire
raises the floor for yourself right they
compound and that you beat every skill
you acquire makes it easier to acquire
complimentary skills and that by adding
one at a time instead of dabbling at a
bunch of things at once
right you your speed of acquisition
accelerates and so starting with like if
I can only learn one thing right now
what would it be and then you create a
plan and you say all right well how how
good do I need to get at this right we
don't need to become experts in anything
sometimes you think about 8020 rule that
acquiring competence is enough for us to
move on and we frame this as a
hypothesis like I think that I can
accomplish X then I will be able to move
on to the next thing for me you know I'm
I'm trying to relearn Spanish to say
relearn because I've forgotten quite a
bit and so my test is I'd like to be
able to have a half-hour conversation in
Spanish with a local without them
knowing that I'm learning Spanish right
and if I think if I can accomplish that
anything anything beyond that is extra
but if I can accomplish that like I get
most of the value and so how do I get
towards that it's like that plan is what
is the what is the most direct path
towards having 30 minute conversation
with a native speaker it's probably
having very short conversation with
non-native speaker and then working my
way up to longer conversations with more
accent but you would you see once you
know what your heading it's very easy to
create a clear path to get there and
it's much more effective way of learning
so that's that's really what I recommend
is you know for me my dream was I just
wanted to spend all day learning things
but I realize like the only point of
acquiring skills is using them and so
let's start from what skills do I need
and how can I effectively acquire them
so that accomplish the things I actually
want to do yeah there's a an analogy
that youssef one of the co-hosts uses
where he talks about his ruthless
indexing of information and he says he's
got he's gonna kill me if I get this
wrong
I think he's Evernote has like over a
thousand summaries of one kind or
another end and he's done T's done two
degrees one of which was medicine he
runs an online business but he also
coaches people for online business and
then also is into like highly end of
meditation all this sort of stuff
and you just think like that there is
just this ruthless indexing of all this
sort of thing but it will be much more
useful to have had ten books and
implemented all of it then it would have
been to have had a thousand and you can
just reference it and then maybe
remember some of the bits that we've
gone through on that so Chris I've
absolutely loved today one question and
this is it might be a difficult one a
lot of people might be thinking there
are Barina I'm gonna bring out don't you
worry I'll bring on a lot of people
might be thinking this all sounds great
Chris parks productivity guru but I
don't know where to start I don't know
what I'm supposed to do maybe they've
got experiment without limits in front
of them and I think you say in that that
it's not necessarily a chronological
book it's not necessarily done in order
and I know that if I was to say this
view you would say well let's have a
discussion about the bottlenecks that
you are facing and we will tell you to
go on a chapter like that in in that
particular way but let me ask you more
difficult question and it is if you were
to pick one of the chapters that you've
got so you have goals systems habits
routines time attention energy
procrastination mental game and learning
if you were to pick one of those to give
to the broadest cross-section of people
which one do you think brings the most
results on the back end if you if you
could give most people one chapter what
would it be
no that's a good it's a very good
question I think I would have to go with
goals I I really come down to that
having everything progresses naturally
from a strong foundation and that a lot
of wasted effort comes from not knowing
what we want so having a structured
process in place for determining what do
we want to accomplish and how do we get
there I think a lot of other advice
becomes obvious where if we if we have a
clear idea of where we're going we
automatically offer
identify opportunities to take action in
that direction and so well I mean
setting goals is primarily a series of
prompts which is just attacking this
question from different angles of what
do I want I think that everything
reduces down to having a good answer of
that question that we cannot move until
we determine where we're moving so that
I think that's the chapter that's most
broadly applicable to anyone and then I
think we can all myself included have
more clarity on what we're trying to
accomplish you know I believe that a
minute spent thinking about what we want
to accomplish returns 10x and probably
more because we don't go after things
that aren't that important to us and we
go after things that we want in a very
effective way now that being said my
idea with putting this out there is that
it's useful to anyone no matter what
stage in the road journey they are and I
have what I call the performance
assessment which is a short quiz which
is free and available to anyone on my
website that's the forcing function comm
slash assessment where I ask them
questions which will help you identify
where is your current personal
bottleneck where is your best
opportunity for growth and anyone who
you know takes a few minutes to complete
that I reply to what I think is the best
experiment within the best chapter in
the workbook for them yeah I realize I
mean my estimate is that you know it
would take someone you know 20 to 30
hours to work their way through this
there's a lot here and I think of
experiment without limits as a reference
guide that people can come back to as
needed and that the most important thing
is determining oh man this is a lot
where should I start
so I'd like to eliminate that sort of
friction four people said hey based on
what you need right now
I'd recommend starting here so yeah
that's that's something that I offer -
to anyone that's the first inflection
calm slash assessment and yet experiment
without limits which we've been talking
about a lot today I hope if it's
something that
you you can download it for free at the
forcing function comm slash workbook
amazing everything which we have gone
through today will be linked in the show
notes below I tell you what I'm gonna
finish on this note and talking about
the checklist that you have and then the
review on the back end and then the
subsequent book experiment without
limits you know that reminds me of
reminds me of Jordan Peterson's online
courses have you done those yeah so
understand myself calm and future
authoring or self authoring calm it's so
similar it's like this is what you are
and these are some of the things you
need to know about you and this is tasks
which you go through did you ever think
about that when you were doing this it's
it's just I haven't such a similarity in
an awesome way
no I I'm honored for the comparison I'm
a big fan of Peterson I see this as many
of the things that I talk about aren't
my own invention that this is a
collection of what I have found to
generalize the most from a variety of
sources whether things that I've read
things that I've tried things that
clients do that works for them and so
I'm happy to hear that what I have to
say is said elsewhere because it's it's
validation that what I have to say works
right it's like the value here is not in
the information the value here is in the
application and so I say is like do any
course that you're actually going to
finish right that they you know there's
there's nothing out there that you can
read that's going to change your life
but until you apply it and then who
knows amazing a good analogy that I
remember there from one of the guys was
that you don't go to an art gallery
because the artists that made the work
are in there you went because they
display a well curated list of art and
this is the same thing
James clear Tommy Cabot's probably
probably the best book that I've read
this year in terms of nonfiction again
nothing all that stuff's available
online but it's curated together in it's
delivered in context and all that sort
of stuff Chris van today has been
amazing I I know that I'm gonna get
hassled to get you back on so I hope
the ready and willing for a second
episode because you will you will be
getting an invite for it everything that
we have linked will be in the show notes
below if we go to the forcing function
comm slash assessment and see if we can
run Chris into the ground and totally
ruin his day by making him do absolutely
loads of these reviews back to us that
would be great
links to experiment without limit it's
only ninety pages something like that
quite sure book ninety-one pages like
it's ninety pages long it's an e-book
and it's free read it on a Kindle get it
on your computer I will be going through
this I'm actually going to be going
through with a couple of my clients as
well so if you are listening and you
want to go through it with me feel free
to drop me a message at Chris will X
wherever you follow me and I'll tell you
where I'm up to we can kind of do like a
Chris sparks productivity book club
thing and see if we can see if we can
make ourselves a little bit more
productive and performance a little bit
more piqued if people want to get in
touch Chris other than the forcing
function why can they find you thanks
for having me on Chris it's been an
honor and a privilege if you're doing a
part two would love to you know keep
talking about this stuff kind of
check-in how things are going yeah and
yeah they like this doesn't need to be a
solo journey the the science is really
clear that if you have someone you care
about a friend and a family member who's
interested in these things a podcast
podcast oh yeah if you do it together
you greatly increase your chances of
following through and taking action so
yeah highly encourage that if is
something I said today you know
resonated you know please get in touch I
said my company's the forcing function
so that's the forcing function calm I'm
on all the usual social media channels
at at sparks remarks and you know I'd be
happy to hear it from me yeah I'd be
happy to hear from you is like I put
this out there to help people and so if
people are using this tell me what's
useful anything you've got out of it
like that's very useful feedback for me
and it would it would really be
validating to hear that you know
something I said today was valuable
something he found in his limits without
valuable so yeah send me a message
would love to continue this are fine
Chris thank you so much amazing thank
you very much guys you know what find us
please like share subscribe do all that
good stuff if you are listening for the
first time give me five stars wherever
you are listening because it really does
make me happy honestly I'm in the midst
of freshers freshers week nightmares at
the moment so any little any little
highlight in my day is great Chris until
next time thank you
[Music]
you